in the gold medal and then this year all
in being 13 focus Mouse has to carry
wild shot off the glass it goes down
trying to come off his body and shortcut
that screen great screen by Bozek to get
it through James on the flush
but like a great point tip by Mozgov but
right to curry curry behind the back
close to the basket pension
laughs except occurs in Piketon all
right doors for the first time as season
the Warriors didn't reach 65 hurries
pass deflected by Dellavedova
go to the alley of the change
it's a three-point game
very guarded by James curry gets away he
slips inside again left handed that's it
as a just right-hand shot won't go fight
for the rebound
here comes James Forster Dellavedova
alley-oop to James and he throws it down
what is it tech you got to protect the
three-point line
[Applause]
the sensational offensive talents nearly
falls drives now spins back to follow a
shot it's good very urban Irving and
curry one on one Irving puts it up let's
go Kyrie Irving from downtown and the
Cavaliers by three games
oh what a crossover and finish LeBron
James a freight train just three for 12
to start for the Warriors
Ervin shake and bake and drills it
games of these finals he's got a play
back turns it over James keeps his
dribble somehow revering back to Jay
haha oh sit down who's strong gets his
own rebound Kyrie Irving crossover Calix
who's a nas from the crowd or the cat's
back up by five
23 for Kyrie Irving on 9 of 15 a month
misses rebound taken by Iguodala
they go down with a curry back there go
down up for the lamp Oh blocked by James
LeBron James with the rejection love to
in down finds James James blocked by
Iguodala ball loose much data bounds by
James and it's Golden State ball with
ten point four remaining actually James
got away with contact on the strip by
eight without outstanding defense the
best hands in the business if you have
played like 12 games in 47 games 40
Sunday 3 to Durant meanwhile James has
been to the free-throw line eight times
already here the first Curry's got
Tristan Thompson fakes drives layup
as on James finds Miggy Nikki looking to
post-up stolen by James James drives
hard and brings it down
didn't want to pick up two quick ones
you know that last game alley-oop to
Duran and he puts it in like that last
possession when I'm talking about
selective running with Coach talk
James trying to harass hurry hurry off
the dribble and off the class
ass inside Tristan Thompson finds James
a lot of thunderous dunks here in the
opening period I don't know about this
but Rihanna just walked in front of me
are you kidding me on the floor but more
importantly at times 431 the Walter
Kennedy is Steph Curry train
corner Darren Williams has come on now
for Cleveland pass up some group
veterans on their bench pass all the way
from and Durant throws it down
it was a turnover Jeff lepak ability for
a big man that pass by curry stolen by
James iguodala's back and Chiefs throws
it right down in his face for the
Cavaliers game 7 Mike he gets 14
rebounds in 30 minutes and he had a push
he's a plus 19 James drives hard inside
pants at home LeBron James a Power Move
play LeBron James has really been
deferential here in the second half
[Applause]
block by Durant
his fifth protection of the game
Oh
James blows past Durant lace it up 17
points and eight rebounds already for
LeBron James Durant on the pull-up at
the buzzer Kevin Durant knocks down the
three they'll review it but he got it
off in time and between Ian love get
caught up the truth very upset
James drive scoop length pass to himself
and he draws it down
we went up in the air that know where to
go almost as many turnovers as they do
field goals hurry find some room knocks
down a two-pointer timeout Cleveland
forcing him to defend either Kyrie Allah
bronze coming off James on the drive get
still around
James whips it out the quarter Kyrie
Irving cuts lay out X to the I reading
does it again
how did he make this shot everything
goes to mega dollar get to the paint
trying to spit and lost it
bigger dolla pushing goes all
that's Knutson can't get it to go here
comes Darren Williams pushing it up the
floor finds James James goes by and
throws it down
Durant kind of backed off a little bit
with the two fouls sections here in the
first quarter for Smith
Irving Russell's are the drive off the
glass that's not fair that's flat-out
not fair James inside on a gorgeous beat
look Kevin Love won't go rebound
stripped green picks it up the ran back
in the game drives past Korver draws the
foul shots good and one six steals in
the game as well that a huge impact to
spikes shooting poorly
photo fiery Oberg putting on his toe
[Music]
Durant's ow shot goes in and one
he had one of those in Game one and a
chance for a three-point play here
[Music]
[Applause]
Irving draws up to Allen knocks it down
Kyrie Irving with a circus shot and a
chance for a four-point play JaVale
McGee you just checked in throws it
ahead here's Durant across the lane
allowing LeBron James of kitchen
Korver's comeback in urban spins urban
drive gets inside throws it up makes it
home as the buzzer sounds
brilliance by Kyrie Irving pokes talks
about the effort Kevin Durant is putting
in to set the tone early in his ballgame
hurry trying to draw the foul still gets
it a go Steph Curry leaving left to try
and draw the contact another one of
those circus threes now hood picks them
up on the switch shot clock at five
Kevin Durant way outside delivers Kevin
Durant from downtown that's a six point
game that's the same spot in Game three
last year I ran up top Iguodala
Durant finds Iguodala goes inside and
throws it down LeBron James five to
shoot
biggie hooks it away James up-and-under
throws it off the backboard shuffle in a
perfect pass to himself
he's been a nice boost for Terron Lu
he's talented now offensively count it
and one
reven directed